just a remarkable interview with former
President Bill Clinton for decades as
you watched both Clinton's had license
to do essentially whatever they wanted
to do and they did fellow Democrats
wouldn't criticize them and neither with
their obedient toady's in the media the
Clintons ran the Democratic Party so
they were too important to be held
accountable that has changed
Bill Clinton is now politically
irrelevant so there's no longer any
reason to protect him the media smell
blood here for examples what happened
when Bill Clinton visited the Today show
this morning to sell a new book the
conversation went directly to Monica
Lewinsky watch but you didn't apologize
to her I have not talked to her do you
feel I thought it were in Apollo I do I
I do no I never talked to her but I did
say publicly on more than one occasion
that I was sorry
ouch he almost lost it then sort of
recovered then he went on to explain
that even though Monica Lewinsky's life
was completely destroyed by that
experience well he himself anon to
become the single richest former
president in history he somehow is the
real victim here watch this do you think
differently or feel more responsibility
no I felt terrible then nobody believes
that I got out of that for free I left
the White House sixteen million dollars
in debt I've had nothing but women
leaders in my office since I left you
are giving one side and omitting mr.
president I'm not I'm not trying to
present aside you think further than
Kennedy should resign do you believe
President Johnson should resign one
should ask you these questions because
of the way you formulate the questions
out she went on like that it was
pathetic that's pretty much it for Bill
Clinton's life as a public figure it is
over but what are the rest of us learn
from watching all of this well if you're
a progressive leader the lesson probably
is not don't abuse women or even treat
the people around you as you would like
to be treated relatively few elected
Democrats could live up to those
standards no the question is this don't
lose power as long as you are useful to
the left nothing you do will be held
against you could literally
no drive off a bridge and kill a woman
in a drunk driving accident and still
remain the most admired Democratic
senator but grow old in irrelevant
next thing you know they'll be asking
you nasty questions about your
impeachment